What's up everybody? I got my guys in
the house. We got Muhammad Mike from
inspiring philosophy. We got the Islamic
eliminator himself from apologetics road
show. David Wood, the Dizzle in the
house. What's up fellas? What's up? How
you doing?
>> Now, now listen, listen, listen guys,
guys, there's been a lot going on. We
have had and we have seen one of the
biggest Dawah meltdowns in Dawah
history. Now you guys David, you've been
in the game longer than I have. I'm kind
of the newbie on the scene. IP, you've
been around. You guys have seen these
guys. You guys have debated these guys.
What in the world are we seeing when it
comes to meltdowns? Like Muhammad
Hijab's meltdown after what's been going
on the these past couple weeks. Yeah,
this is this is huge. Normally, and I've
been saying this for a long time.
Dawah guys don't last long. They have a
pretty, you know, short career cycle
because Dawah Dawah guy will come along
and he's got some new bag of tricks or
something like this. He's got some new
trick, some new thing he does and so on.
And that'll work for a while cuz you can
catch people off guard, you can catch
people off guard with some new argument
or something like this. Like Daniel,
Daniel Hakikachou when he came out and
he starts he'll cite like 27 different
studies in his opening statement and
stuff and his opponent hasn't read any
of these studies. So he's just like
people take his word that all these
studies confirm what he's saying and so
on. So he had that going and that worked
for a while until he faced IP until he
faced [laughter] IP and IP actually read
all the stuff and then exposed him for
just completely misrepresenting things
and now it doesn't work anymore. So
that's usually what happens. So they'll
they'll come out, they'll have a new way
of doing things, they'll take off in
popularity, people will catch on to the
tricks and then they'll jump but
normally they just start fading
afterwards, right? They fade into
irrelevance and that's why the Dawah
guys back in 2005 they're they're not
around anymore and they were different
from the Dawah guys in 2010 and then and
the the 2010 guys were different from
the 2015 guys and so on. So Hijab, even
though know only started in like 2018 or
2000 whatever when people started
hearing about him. He's had a long run.
He's had a long run. This makes him a
senior citizen in Dawah cuz he's lasted
like he's lasted like 8 years now,
right? That's a long that's a long
career in Dawah, but it's it's because
these guys are such like because he's a
narcissist, it's it's it's harder for
him, right? Like
>> Mhm. Everything's supposed to
everything's supposed to revolve around
him. Hey, I'm going live. I'm going to
jump on the live. It's going to be the
most popular show in the world. I'm
going to be cooking everybody. I'm going
to make tons of money so I can pay off
Douglas Murray and just blows up in his
face and it doesn't work anymore. Why?
The tricks aren't working, right? People
are people are onto all his tricks.
They're not working anymore and he just
keeps getting cooked. And so what do you
do, man? He's total meltdown, man. He
can't his brain can't process it and so
his brain is is actually melting. So we
we got, you know, somebody like IP and I
say this all the time. I have never seen
someone draw in as many flakes as IP has
when it comes to scheduled debates, when
it comes to you know, events already
planned, contracts signed, you know,
he's already talked about the agreements
in the email and all of a sudden this
Muslim debater got has a toothache,
needs needs surgery, mama sick, wife
arguing, they can't they somehow they
can't get to the debate.
>> Yeah, your bad luck, IP. Bad luck, man.
You show up and you
people like saw me debate Daniel
Haqiqatjou and realized I actually do
the reading and now we're just I getting
all these flakes. Like I when I when I
went to the UK for the first time,
unbelievable. Was trying to set up a
debate with a Muslim and they contacted
some of mom and he's like, "Yeah, I
would love to come back on. By the way,
who's the Christian?" So they sent him
my info and then within 2 hours he was
like, "Oh, I I just came down with a
fever and you guys know these things can
last up to 10 days." Well, that's very
specific. So I won't be available in 2
days. But yeah, so you I have I've had
numerous instances like that. Like as
you know, I challenged Hamza's Den, and
he agreed. And then later he's like,
"Yeah, I don't think so. I don't think
so. I'm going to back out of this." And
we know about my
one that one guy who like had to
reschedule three times with me and kept
making different excuses. And
man, but then I decided like I'll just
show up to Hijab's stream, maybe I can
talk to him. And that didn't happen. He
ran faster than a speeding bullet. He
made Uthman look slow, which says a lot
considering it's Sheikh Uthman, who's
one of the fastest runners I've ever
seen. Uthman Bolt, Sheikh Uthman Bolt.
>> Mhm. Now, now this is this is getting
serious. Speaking of this stuff. So,
Muhammad Hijab, you mentioned it, he
started going live now. Started doing
live streams inviting non-Muslims to
come and engage with him and debate him.
And on one of those days, yours truly
showed up. I showed up.
And That That was the first day, wasn't
it? Wasn't that the first one? Uh yes,
it was the first one. And I showed up
and decided to run the Islamic dilemma,
absolutely humiliated him, embarrassed
him, outclassed him, even though I don't
have any degrees, I don't have any
certificates, I don't have any diplomas.
And yet I was able to outclass him in
every level of the game. Ever since that
discussion, we have seen a historic
meltdown. That is like I don't know how
he's going to recover from this. It's
just been one thing after another after
another, right? And so So, the the start
of the meltdown is me destroying him.
And then, in response, the video's going
viral on my channel, he copyright
strikes it after giving verbal agreement
that he I can have it on my channel. I
can go live or whatever. Strikes the
video. And after that, I mean,
everybody, even atheists and big
channels are covering this. It's doing
the opposite effect, him trying to
suppress it. And so, everybody wants to
see this. Now, everybody's talking about
it now. And then not only that, he's
striking everybody that's doing reviews
and clipping it. He's striking
everybody. And then it's like he gets
PSD because he does the same thing the
next week. And then this guy shows up.
IP. And IP, what? What what what what
what what happened when he when you
showed up, man? What was it? Man, so
yeah. He wised up. He kind of Yeah, he
got that That's what he looked like. No,
he wised up, right? Like after his after
his total meltdown with you, he was
like, "Okay, if someone if someone who's
going to cook me shows up, don't don't
let him don't let him, guys. Rescue me."
My favorite part of that is he tried to
play it off like this was just a
unexpected thing. Like I go live at the
same time he does because I don't want
him to try to do this copyright crap.
So, if I'm live, he can't YouTube will
be much more much more on my side on
that issue. So, like I'm live. More
people are watching my live just waiting
for him to pull me up, which you know
was psychologically bothering him.
>> Oh yeah. Oh yeah. So then, like in the
middle of it, all of a sudden, Dean
responds comes out of nowhere. Wasn't
planned. He's in Australia, and he even
admits it's 5:00 a.m. there. So, you
know they called him and said They
called that boy. They called that boy.
Get up. Get up. The mafia boss needs you
right now. Get on the stream. And he's
like, "Okay, well, my camera's not even
ready, so give me some time." Comes back
the moment he's got his camera up,
they're like, "Okay, well, let's let's
just choose at random a debate opponent
for you, Dean. I don't know. You need ME
NEED MONEY. GO."
>> [laughter]
>> YOU GOT THIS, DEAN.
LITERALLY WENT OFF SCREEN, MAN. Took
himself off the screen to leave it up to
Dean to save the day. That was that was
one of the that was pathetic. I know
Islam doesn't believe in atonement, but
that day Dean was the sacrificial lamb
they tried to throw out. Yeah, he was.
Now, it gets worse though because not
he's not just running now. Now, he goes
live again and goes on this rant, this
weird creepy rant, this with all these
sexual innuendos about my wife and you,
IP. What the what the what the what
>> And then and then singing, like,
"Mrs. Jones."
Yo, yeah, I had to I uh wash my ears out
with holy water after that. I was like,
"Oh, man, he's try- he wants to violate
me, but he's violating my ears, and
that's bad enough." I haven't seen
anything like that, man. Not not from a
Dawah guy like that.
>> And even even even some of his fellow
Muslims are saying that he he's he he's
either drunk or high or something like
that. So, which means he's
self-medicating after that cuz he was
Remember Avery, when you were on there,
he was much more high energy. He was
much more high energy and stuff like
that. So, he didn't seem like he'd like
been smoking a ton of weed or something
like that getting drunk. But for for
that for that part for that part where
he's talking about your wife and and IP
and stuff like that, he seemed like
stoned [snorts] out of his mind.
>> Yeah.
>> Which means he's like he's
self-medicating with drugs or alcohol to
deal with the humiliation. Mhm. Cuz keep
in mind, in his in his thinking, he's
looking at like you, right? Like you you
you got four, five, six thousand people
watching you live and stuff like that in
his job like, "Oh, this is just a the
the golden age of huge live streams. I
can do this because I'm the most popular
Dawah guy in the world. I will jump on."
And he gets crushed and humiliated and
has to take his own stuff down and
copyright strike it, which means it's
not going anywhere. None of this is
going anywhere. I clicked on the one
from When was it, yesterday? Yeah, yeah.
>> Yeah, so I I clicked on the most recent
one. It was just halfway through just to
just to see who he was talking to. But
he had like a thousand people watching,
which would be which would be That's a
good live stream for for a regular
YouTuber, not for someone who's
supposedly the best in the world and is
taking in and is you know, having a live
calling show. Yeah, live debate calling
show and stuff like that. And he's
getting a fraction of what you get, and
he's the champ. So, yeah, it's breaking
him, man. It's breaking him. It's not
not working for him.
>> I found on Twitter Muslims complaining
about him. I I want to just Can I share
my screen if that's possible? yeah,
>> can. Yeah.
>> So, this Muslim posted this So Daniel
Haqiqatjou decided to defend him. Try
decided to defend him and then Muslims
were complaining. Now, this particular
Muslim later deleted this comment, but I
had already messaged somebody about it
saying "Haha." And then we found him
deleted later. But he says, "He's a
liability to the religion of Islam,
brother."
Look at that. Muslims are saying
Muhammad Hijab is a liability. Now, this
guy Adam deleted this comment under
Daniel Haqiqatjou later. But I still
found bad comments about this. So,
luckily we were able to get a screenshot
of this before he deleted it. But yeah,
and but notice he posted a video on my
channel that fan made about Hijab just
failing to defend the Quran. They're
seeing this stuff. It's bothering them.
And yet he's their top tawaguy. Listen,
you guys chose Hijab through your likes,
your clicks, your views, your shares.
Now you got to reap the consequences.
Yep. This is who your guy is. This is
your face. Now, so and speaking of this
then, going long rants, singing, he's
uh intoxicated off some type of dawa
syrup or whatever cuz he's his mind is
gone. We're seeing this type of fallout
with him and this is this is just
embarrassing. Have we Where do Where
does this rank as far as cuz there's
been some other dawa fallouts throughout
the years, these embarrassing times and
these you know, these mental breakdowns
where they crumble on each other. Uh for
example, we got Yas the Yasir Qadhi
event. Again, conveniently Muhammad
Hijab was part of that. Where you have
the the holes in the narrative. that the
standard narrative has holes in it.
That's what I'm going to say. They they
throw down that video. They they they
delete that video, but it's too late.
Everybody downloaded it. Everybody's
uploading it, clipping it, reviewing it,
going live. And Yasir Qadhi starts
trying to copyright strike folks, right?
Tell us a little bit about that time and
where does that kind of kind of rank
here? I mean, it that's kind of have to
that that has to be number two, right?
>> [laughter]
>> Like these are bigger it's funny that
his job is in is in both of them. I
think the other I think the other
biggest one would be Sheikh Uthman
challenging you to debate and then
hiding inside the mosque and refusing to
refusing to debate. But yeah, the holes
in the narrative interview, that was
that was really the the tipping point,
the biggest tipping point because for
years they had their argument that
there's only one Quran perfect. I have
Dawa books that say there's only one
Quran. There isn't one letter of
difference between any two Qurans in the
world, not one dot of difference. It's
total lie. I mean, absolute complete
total lie. They have different Qurans in
different parts of the world. They have
Dan Brubaker made a video where he
showed 11 textual variants on one page
of a manuscript. So you had them
you could go all the way back. You could
look at their sources where they talked
about disagreements in what's supposed
to be in the Quran and what the correct
reading is. Then you got the manuscript
tradition and guess what? They have all
have all kinds of textual variants in
the manuscript tradition. Then you have
different Qurans in different parts of
the world today. And Muslim leaders were
just lying to people about it. Just just
one Quran perfectly preserved from the
time of
to the time of Muhammad. And then a big
a big turning point was Hatun showing up
at 26 different Arabic Qurans. And this
was just this was just Qurans that she
picked up in Muslim bookstores and stuff
around in different parts of the world.
She's noticing the differences and
stuff. But she shows up 26 different and
and Muslims will say, "No, it's just
different trans No, it's not. It's 26
different Arabic Qurans."
Every one of these is different from
every other one. 26 different Arabic
Qurans. Muslims were accusing her of
printing them herself, like she has a
publishing house, printing them herself
with variants because that's the only
they'd been programmed. Nope, one Quran.
So anyways, kind of that caused kind of
a ruckus in the in the Muslim community
where Muslims are like, "What? You guys
told us perfect preservation. She's
putting Qurans in our faces that have
differences on it. What is this?" Hijab
comes up with the brilliant idea. He's
going to get Sheikh Yasir Qadhi on to
[laughter] to uh
to to show everyone to show everyone
there's no real problem here and it was
a huge disaster. And the reason they had
to take it down is the comments were
filled with this is causing me to doubt
Islam. This is this is this is
destroying my faith in Islam. And so
that they same thing they scrambled take
the videos down. At first they I I
remember the order. First they blocked
comments. They eventually blocked
comments cuz the comment sections were
filled of full of Muslims saying this is
causing them to doubt Islam. Then they
cut out that section of the videos. They
just cut out that section it was just
the rest of it and then they just took
it all down and then they started
copyright striking people and stuff like
that. I was like, "Oh, you guys
uh you guys are realizing uh you done
messed up now, didn't they?"
>> Yeah. It was a wrap after that. So we're
talking about copyright strikes. We're
talking about meltdown. So we So is this
Are we in agreement then? It'll be
Muhammad Now I don't know if this might
be recency bias. I don't know but we I I
don't think we've seen such a meltdown
like this, man. No, right. Yeah, and and
we and we're kind of like right at the
beginning or right in the middle of it,
right? Like something could happen where
he hypothetically he could turn things
around and then this won't be the
biggest meltdown cuz you know something
will happen afterwards where he will
shockingly redeem himself or something
like that. But if this keeps going in
the direction it is, I mean this guy's
this guy's going down like the
Hindenburg, man. The Hindenburg. So we
got one, Muhammad Hijab's recent
meltdown. Two, the meltdown with Yasir
Qadhi and the holes in the narrative.
And then three, Uthman challenging me
publicly to a debate to come to the
mosque at 7:00 p.m. Come, debate. Come,
let's see it. I show up and he stays in
the masjid, doesn't let me come in, says
I can't bring my camera, can't bring my
camera crew, and I can only ask one
question, and then that's it. I got to
take it and leave.
>> We're still waiting. He cannot come on
the screen. So just him. Just him. With
no camera. No camera. But he's asking
for a debate. So can you him come ask
for a debate. Ask for a question. What's
What's it to be? Yeah, that was kind of
That was kind of like the That was kind
of like the uh the the culmination of
it. But, it was everything leading up to
that. It was like where he was invited
onto PBD, and then he
he refused. And then he goes and he lies
to his uh he lies to his people and
said, "They said I would not be allowed
to criticize Christianity." And PBD
called him out. He's like, "You're a
liar, man. We didn't say any of that.
Even ask Eddie from the Dean show." He's
like, "Eddie, you were the one You were
the one setting this up. Did I ever say
one word about that?" And uh so anyway,
he's like banned from PBD now because
because of that. But, then he keeps
rolling with it and it it was it was him
trying to redeem himself after being
exposed for backing down from debating
you guys, and then
um having to lie about why he wouldn't
do it. And so, he's trying to redeem
himself. AND THEN SO, "I CHALLENGE ALL
OF YOU. I CHALLENGE ALL OF YOU. I
CHALLENGE ALL OF YOU TO DEBATE." We all
accept.
He backs down from everybody.
>> [laughter]
>> And still acts like we're running. And
then remember, he's like, "I want you
all to come to my live call-in show on
Christmas Eve." It's like Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> Are you kidding me? Masha Allah. I'd
like to add in a a fourth Dawah
meltdown. Very recent. We already forgot
about There's been so many Dawah melt
meltdown. But, I'll agree with this
ranking. But, I'll add in number four.
We forgot that just recently, you know,
Jake the Muslim Metaphysician and Daniel
Haqiqatjou their their endless fighting
spilled over into that 8-hour stream.
Where they're fighting with each other,
and then Dean responds comes in, and
then he's fighting with both of them.
And like just the cracks in this idea
that there's so much unity in Islam. You
can see right through it because of
that. Like, it's not even like two on
one. They're all fighting each other in
that long stream. So, like this idea
they always push about, "We're so
unified in Islam unlike all those
Christian denominations." That stream
demonstrated that's all a lie. Like,
behind the scenes you guys all hate each
other. You're always fighting. And so, I
add that as number four. And yeah, and
that's uh there's a reason for that.
It's the the entire dawa scene, not
everyone, but the entire dawa scene is
populated mostly by narcissists, right?
They're the ones who they just become
popular. Narcissists are good at taking
advantage of gullible people to get
attention for themselves and get people
to
uh rally around them and basically
uh worship them. And so, you know,
narcissists just look at the ummah and
they're like, "Oh, goldmine, jackpot
right here. I can I can uh here's This
is the community for me." And so, like
Muhammad Hijab, narcissist, Ali Dawah,
narcissist, uh Sheikh Uthman, total
narcissist, and so on. And so, again,
these guys are good at becoming popular
and thumping their chests and stuff like
that. But guess what? They're not good
at working well together because each
one wants to be the ultimate center of
attention. And so, they eventually just
start just start attacking each other
and uh and that's that's what we're
seeing right now. Yep. Well, uh because
of the copyright strike, guys, the video
that uh Muhammad Hijab copyright struck
on our channel and went up with our
discussion should be up within
uh the next week or within the next
week, the video will be back up, and uh
we're going to push it. We're going to
push it, and we'll by by the Lord's
grace, we're going to make it go viral
again cuz it was on its way to hit a
million. He had to stop it. He knew what
he was doing, but he can't stop this.
So, we're going to all push through it.
So, when that comes out, make sure you
guys are commenting, sharing it, liking
it. Uh make sure you guys are reviewing
it, clipping it. You know, put it make
it go everywhere. You understand?
Make it go everywhere. If you believe
that we missed a dawa moment, a dawa
meltdown, let us know in the comments
section. Make sure you guys leave a like
on this video, subscribe to Inspiring
Philosophy, and subscribe to Apologetics
Roadshow. We'll see you guys next time.
Peace.